[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
استراتيجيه الفلسطينيه واضحه في
سلوكه في اداءه وفي مواجهتها لاسرائيل
وللاحتلال الاسرائيلي هذا عدو شمس ومتوحش
وهذه الحكومه برنامجها واضح تماما
عليك ان تدرك تماما وان تصنع جمله من
التكتيكات التي تصب في خدمه استراتيجيتك
في المحصله النهائيه اللي رحيل الاحتلال
[موسيقى]
المركزيه والاستراتيجيه الان هي تثبيت
الشعب الفلسطيني على ارضه امام هذه
السياسه المجرمه الاسرائيليه نحن لا نمتلك
لا دبابات ولا طائرات ولكن نمتلك قرار
واراده شعب يريد ان يبقى على هذه الارض
وان يعيش على هذه الارض وان يواجه هذا
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وان يواجه سياسات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ويجب ان نوظف كل ما
لدينا من امكانيات على الصعيد المحلي
والاقليمي والدولي لخدمه هذا الموضوع وهذا
الهدف هذه الاستراتيجيه الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
عشناه في فتره الشهيد ابو عمار الله يرحمه
انا برايي بانه الشعب الفلسطيني
لدي من الامكانيات والمقومات الداخليه
التي تحصن جبهه الداخليه اكثر بكثير مما
يعتقد البعض لذلك في هناك مؤسسات وفي اطر
هي صاحبه القرار في المحصله النهائيه
وهناك شعب فلسطيني هو صاحب الاختيار
والقرار عبر صندوق الاقتراع لذلك انا
اتمنى ان لا ننزلق كثيرا في
البروبوجنده الموجهه وبالذات موجهه من
خصومنا ومن اعدائنا للاسف الشديد لذلك انا
واثق تماما الشعب الفلسطيني حي ويستطيع ان
يواجه
اي طارئ او اي فراغ ممكن ان يحصل في اي
لحظه
[موسيقى]